One of the beautiful things about looting
and rioting is that it just immediately makes
people's lives better.
They get things that they would otherwise
have to work for weeks or months to get,
they get them in an instant.
The writer and activist Vicky Osterweil is
the latest and most strident defender
of the violence and destruction that's accompanied
more than three months of protests
following the death of George Floyd.
Osterweil argues that in the last years of
Martin Luther King Jr's life, as his focus
moved beyond desegregation and voting rights
and towards promoting socialism,
he had a change of heart about looting and destruction
as a tool for social change.
Though he wasn't calling for violent revolution
she writes,
neither was he chastising or rejecting rioters anymore.
Others have pointed to the famous King line.
In reality, King was unwavering in his commitment
to nonviolence.
Every summer we're going to have this kind
of vigorous protest, my hope is
that it will be nonviolent.
I would hope that we can avoid riots because
riots are self-defeating and socially destructive.
He tried to make his position crystal clear
in that same 1966 interview with 60 minutes
Mike Wallace.
I will never change in my basic idea that
nonviolence is the most potent weapon available
to the Negro in his struggle for freedom and
justice.
And less than a year before his death King
delivered a lecture addressing skeptics
of nonviolence following the 1967 riots.
Many people feel that nonviolence as a strategy
for social change was cremated in the flames
of the urban riots of the last two years.
Yet King doubled down, calling for massive
sustained nonviolent civil disobedience.
In this world nonviolence is no longer an
option for intellectual analysis.
It is an imperative for action.
King considered violent protests to be self-defeating
because as he argued in 1968, every time a
riot develops it makes a right wing takeover
more likely, and helps the segregationist
George Wallace.
Vicky Osterweil writes admiringly of the nationwide
riots that followed King's assassination as
But the Princeton political scientist Omar
Wasow has studied the '68 riots in detail,
finding that they allowed Richard Nixon to
beat Democrat Hubert Humphrey in that year's
presidential race.
As King understood, media coverage was why
looting and violence backfired.
When protesters engaged in violence that predicted
a headline about riots tomorrow, a headline
that was much more likely to focus on crime
and disorder, and public opinion moves very
closely with that.
So when the newspapers are talking about civil
rights, civil rights becomes the most important
problem in public opinion surveys.
And when newspapers are heavily covering crime
and riots, crime and riots become the thing
that is the most important problem.
And so the tactics that are employed by protesters
can really make a powerful impact on how the
media tell the story, which in turn shapes
public opinion.
Some media outlets have opted to downplay
the violence and destruction, but King's warning
and Wasow's research still resonate today
as polls show a sharp downward turn in approval
ratings of the Black Lives Matter Movement
in recent weeks, especially in swing states
like Wisconsin, even before riots hit Kenosha.
Democratic presidential candidate Joe Biden
seems to fundamentally understand that.
Rioting is not protesting, looting is not
protesting.
Which might help explain how he's maintained
the lead so far against an incumbent who's
often fanned the flames with his rhetoric.
If a city or a state refuses to take the actions
that are necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents, then I will deploy
the United States Military and quickly solve
the problem for them.
When King said this he wasn't excusing riots,
but imploring observers to acknowledge the
unjust conditions that contributed to their
emergence in the first place.
Certain conditions continue to exist in our
society, which must be condemned as vigorously
as we condemn riots.
Rioters and looters are at the core of all
of these movements.
The paths forward to social change couldn't
be more clear, persistent nonviolent resistance
as practiced by Martin Luther King, Jr. who
helped achieve historic civil rights legislation,
or rioting and looting, promoted by activists
who believe we need to argue and defend
every tactic that might help us overturn this miserable
world of white supremacy, anti-blackness,
cisheteropatriarchy, capitalism, empire, and property.